my guest tonight appeared in knocked up
tropic thunder
man seeking woman and the blockbuster
how to train
your dragon movies love those films now
he's directed and stars in
the new movie random acts of violence
please welcome
uh our good friend jay barachel jay how
are you
i'm well conan thank you how are you
doing i'm i'm doing all right thanks for
asking me this is um
we're in very strange uh situation
now for a year i keep acting like this
is a new phenomenon i can't believe it's
been almost
a year i'm so used to talking to you in
person
we always have a good time i don't even
know where you are right now where are
you
i'm in uh the guest room of someone else
i was gonna say someone else's house
which it is because it's an airbnb i'm
in montreal uh as a
yeah i'm in montreal okay it's so funny
because it looks like you're on the run
from the law it's just this all has the
i track down jay barachel who you all
know is on the run
i've tracked him down
it's 5am and the shelling has just
started
are you doing okay so you're staying in
this airbnb in montreal
how are you adapting to all this is this
because i've noticed two things
there are people that uh just can't
handle this quarantine this lockdown
this pandemic
and there are other people that are sort
of oddly suited to it where are you
what's most depressing i think is that
like last year was
by far by far the most relaxed i've been
in my adult life
you know it's funny it's it is like
we're not supposed to admit that but
there are some of us that are
getting really good sleep um
you know i don't know about you but i've
spent i get great sleep
and uh i've been just basically wearing
leisure wear
um you know for uh and it's gotten to
the point now where i think i'm putting
it in my will that when my time comes
i want to i want to be buried i want in
the casket i want to be in like
lululemon you know
yeah it's a sad state of affairs no it
certainly is i'm in a post jeans world
i i i can't conceive of ever wearing
them
if somebody wasn't paying me you know
i'm i'm
doing this tv show now and now i have to
squeeze into the damn things
yeah just like yeah i i didn't miss that
at all
um yeah no if if i wish to
if i was to pan down you would see it's
a it's it's squarely uh
party on the bottom that's no never
never say in that sentence again
exactly don't ever and you shouldn't
have said it the first time i'd edit it
out but
who has the money for that um i think
last time you were on the show in person
you were with your fiance
at the time yes uh and i know that you
were planning to get married really soon
and i think you got married just as this
thing locked everybody down didn't you
yeah we we we really got married
we we got married and that was that and
i
i'll be honest i when all this started i
really thought we'd
kill each other um and
strangely that's not what happened um
and it ended up being kind of nice
however there was a point last summer
when
uh i my wife answered
a question really kind of short or
something i was like why are you so
crabby and she was like well listen
nothing personal but it's been
it's been only you uh all year and
it was like i am deeply sympathetic it's
been 38 years for me
so i i i i get you completely
now jay you can probably tell that
during quarantine i've worked i work out
like crazy
um there's they're actually my assistant
is laughing behind this curtain
um no but i am known for
my uh you know my physicality and my
sensuality and so
i have worked very hard during
quarantine at maintaining
what the public demands from me what
about you or have you
have you worked at it at all are you are
you are you taking care of yourself
well i i so you and i we answer to the
same masters
um and so your concerns are my concerns
and so i look
from here on down that's the money maker
when you're stuck in quarantine you
gotta you kind of run out of excuses to
give your wife for why you won't do yoga
with her so um i eventually kind of
caved
taken up snowshoeing snowshoeing
yes so uh um so that's that that's
that's my workout
did you uh are you a skier i'm just
imagining you
you must be a skier you had to be
growing up
so i've gone skiing once i went skiing
once
and snowboarded once uh and never again
each time uh the the skiing the one time
i went skiing was
um it with hindsight i suspect it was
like
my father's fumbling attempt to save his
marriage took us
all on a ski vacation um
spoiler alert my mom left him two years
later
and uh sorry i'm laughing i should say
sorry but what are you gonna do
the marriage broke up and you were
scarred
and there's your impressionable 14
year old robbed of my male role model
and uh uh but so they they got us all
snow suits
and we went down to vermont which again
exercising futility because we lived in
montreal don't need to go to vermont to
go
skiing but whatever anyway we went and
and um everybody made fun of my snow
suit
all the rich american kids laughed at my
snow suit and made jokes about what you
get that at walmart and
i was like yeah i think i did actually
and uh
and i i gave up after the like sixth
time i ate it
and i was just lying there like
gear all over the place like a like a
plane crash and my arm's at kimbo and
his kids going above me on the gondola
literally laughing like nelson
and uh you know i used to i'm from
boston so
my brother and i used to go up skiing in
vermont
so i would have been it's possible
i would have been up there laughing at
you from a gondola
you know yeah i realize the time doesn't
exactly lined up i would probably
started my
my showbiz career by then but it's
possible it's possible
that i saw you as like a 12 or 14 year
old
and uh leaned out of a gondola and
laughed at you because that's the kind
of [ __ ] i was
at the very least your spiritual
descendants uh
laughed at me yeah
hey i want to talk about your movie
which i watched last night and i really
enjoyed
random acts of violence this is a real
achievement
you wrote this you directed it you're in
it
and this is really this amazing vision
that you've brought to life
and it is an intense film it's the kind
of movie
that uh provokes a lot of strong
reactions from people
and you say you've been hearing uh
strong reactions on both sides
yeah yeah that's that's and i kind of
set out to do that i i wanted to make a
movie that like
you know for people that kind of
connected to it it would be something
special for them and
but it but anything short of that i
wanted you to to hate it
and and question my uh right to make it
and and and that's what's happened man
it it's like
i don't know about you but like when i
see a movie he's got like 40 50
on rotten tomatoes that is infinitely
more compelling to me as a viewer than
one that's like 90
across the board right because 50 means
they did something and took some chances
and
and and committed and so oh man what's
amazing though is that like a lot of the
like
haters um ended up paying us compliments
like you know someone calling us uh
lurid
and uh humorless and and cruel and
garish and unpleasant and i mean like
man those are all adjectives i'd take
any day of the damn week for a horror
movie
man like it would be awful if everyone
was like ah it was so
lovely and and warm and and i and i left
there feeling better than i
showed up there i was like oh god i
would just kill myself
right right no one says that about texas
chainsaw massacre or any of the classics
you know took the whole family all of us
forgot our problems
for an hour and a half yes no i don't
want the marley and me
you know uh lying for my movie one of
the aspects of the movie that i found
really compelling
is that it's about someone
who uh i want to use the correct term
it's not really a comic book the the the
main character you'd call it more
he's a graphic artist novel yeah graphic
novelist
and he's uh written these comp these
books
about uh that
you know are really about the horror
genre and
it is a horror movie but the main theme
of it
is about whether it's okay to exploit
violence and horror and it had me
um like all of us kind of sometimes
getting into the violence
and then at the same time you're asking
the question that they're asking the
protagonist
you're profiting off this and it's this
i don't know i thought was a very it was
sort of a good mind puzzle
thank you that it was it was sort of you
know my writing partner jesse and i
kind of unpacking our fascinations if
that makes sense you know a
big horror fan big true crime fan and
and i noticed
something which is that i couldn't name
any of the kids that
uh that michael myers or freddie or
jason killed
with the exception of maybe like you
know the main characters but for the
most part i couldn't leave any of the
kids they off
and then i also kind of realized that
like the same way i could name
dahmer gacy bundy the zodiac
richard ramirez all these and i could
and i could list off all their stats
like they were athletes
but again i couldn't name a single
person that they had murdered
yeah and and that didn't quite sit well
with me
and so the the kind of meditation of me
trying to unpack some of that stuff
is is kind of what makes up the dna of
random acts of violence
yes it's really well done we have a clip
here this is a clip that is um
that you selected i actually love this
scene because the location is so
eerie but you guys and i know that you
picked this because
there's no spoilers in it but uh you uh
the protagonist is the um graphic
uh graphic novelist and you are his kind
of manager
and you guys are on this road trip to go
down to comic-con and you've stopped off
and you've gone into this really
freaking weird
like it's not a 7-eleven it's it's kind
of posing as a 7-eleven
but it's it's it's one of those places
that maybe even doesn't exist anymore if
it does exist it exists way off the main
drag
correct correct yeah the the world's
crappiest gas station
all right let's take a look at this clip
from random acts of violence
on bird isn't he holy
[ __ ]
i didn't know a place like this still
existed
what do they even sell here uh pickled
eggs
yeah but i mean i meant let me rephrase
that what do people actually buy from
here in the last
nothing apparently um is any of this
uh getting your creative juices flowing
you know
give it a rest this could be the scene
of a massacre final issue starting to
get into your head now no
it's my job it's coming all right that's
the whole point of me designing you know
the
road trip all right it's just like
tingle stimulates some
inspiration final issue inspiration is
the objective
or conversely it doesn't have to be the
last issue but
it's the lat we've talked about it man
i'm i can't it's not healthy
you know you don't have to wake up in
cold sweat whatever it takes i wish i
wanted to eat some of this food so i
could make you
pay for it no no no none of this is
edible um
oh my god look at this
thing janked what
is this supposed to be looks to me like
just a sold out rack of slasher man are
you thinking what i'm thinking
you know i'm thinking what you're
thinking buddy it's time for a refill
right it is we got a trunk full of them
or we could maybe do that the next town
over
is this kind of it's a little bit much
for them no
mcbain and mcbain where was that by the
way
that i think is uh slightly outside of a
small town called bethany ontario which
is itself
maybe a thousand people or something so
yes it is so
everything was like within an hour and a
half two hours uh um outside of ontario
so like
yeah the the they are send of some
highway off ramp
yeah well i'm never going there
hopefully me neither hopefully because
that really looked like an unpleasant
place
random acts of violence will be
available on video on demand
uh digital hd and dvd and blu-ray on
february
uh 16th and i congratulate you this is a
this is a remarkable
uh effort that you've put in and uh i
think it's really cool that you pulled
this off
thank you conan that means the world man
thank you so much and thank you for
having me
all right yeah and uh congrats on
everything and we'll uh i hope to talk
to you soon in person
all right i look forward i look forward
to it my friend